[Music]
captain
she's highly trained
deception infiltration
extraction
special forces
[Music]
hyden versio
inferno squad
commander
you version be important
look at me
so let's talk facts
that's what i'm here for
you have the activation code
i've got the ability to help you out
just give me the code
you know we can really use someone like
you
just help me and i'll help you it's that
easy
i'm gonna get what i want eventually
my best technicians are slicing into
your droid right now
take out my offer
all i want is the code
the empire's time has come
you don't have to go down with it
you're right
the empire's time has come
[Music]
vz
six two six
[Music]
vz
six two six
what have we here
an id10 tactical droid
you're way more advanced than the id9
slicing into you is not gonna be easy
might i suggest a less invasive
procedure wish i could but we don't have
the droid's access code might i suggest
finding the access code
the captain's working on that in the
detention center
until then the only way to access
destroys data is to pry the memory core
out of its shell analysis
which can't do anything if the droid is
deactivated
until it here's the access code this
id10 can't do a thing
yes just let me work in peace
[Music]
then come find me
send reinforcements immediately
[Music]
use the ventilation system to reach me
wow
[Music]
you worry too much
next time
[Music]
thanks
command is expecting updates before
indoors
[Music]
there are too many rebels outside myself
[Applause]
[Music]
located
there are too many rebels outside myself
[Music]
foreign
terminals
contact me when it's done
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're done regroup with me
it's time
[Music]
foreign
you're close
and on time
let's go
[Music]
agent do you read
you're right on time
i'm moving to the communication center
copy that
once i've located and destroyed the
stolen imperial message i will signal
for extraction
after that we'll figure out what to do
[Music]
to be fair we're operating outside
protocol
we should have
we will divert the empire's attention
away from solace
the rebels still think we don't know
about salas
they have no idea what's waiting for
them
we need to keep it that
rebels way
that transmission before i delete it
everything will fall apart
[Music]
to meet with the rest of the point
like that
[Music]
transmission
will trigger their alarm be ready for
extraction
understood
for the last time please stop
interrupting me
imperial encryption is fair
i've located the encrypted intel
this is not great
we have new orders
the imperial fate will move
[Music]
so is the corvus
what's up
[Applause]
[Music]
go for the sun
destroy go
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
destroyed
back
[Music]
oh
agent
prepare for extraction
[Music]
uh